[Music]
the beale is with us nabeel is in
atlanta hi nabil how are you
hi dave thank you for having me on the
show sure what's up
so i'm a 23 year old with about 80 000
85 000 saved i've got about 25k in my
roth ira and 401k and about 60k in
investments in index funds which with
i'm looking to purchase my first home
wow where'd you get all that make about
a hun
so i work at a job i've just been
following your principal since i
graduated college and i've kind of every
stimulus every uh piece of extra money
that i've gotten i'm kind of just put
away and tried to save so not counting
your roth you got like 145 000 bucks
no no so it's it's total of about 85
it's about 60 in the oh the whole game
is that okay
yes okay got it um
so basically i make about 120 000
at a job that i really relocated to
about six months ago and because i'm
already traveling i just moved back in
with my parents
so i'm looking to buy a home with which
i would use as both a primary residence
and also simultaneously rent part of it
out to make up for the costs of me not
being there because of my work travel
what are you doing it's now a good
so essentially i'm a project manager
setting up new warehouses across the
country
man you're killing it good job dude
you're killing me thank you
do you like the job
yeah i do i do i'm only uh it kind of
complicates the
housing because i'm only in
my home city for about four days a month
i'm kind of just ongoing hotels uh so
that's why i'm trying to see whether now
it's kind of a good time for me to buy a
townhouse or a small house in the 250 to
300 000 range i would for this purpose
and how do i kind of find it i wouldn't
either i wouldn't i wouldn't either
you're not there enough to manage it
that's it pops freeze and bust the whole
thing will melt before you get back
okay so how would you kind of recommend
that someone like myself uh in the
coming years say i were to stay in the
shop how would you recommend i
pursue homeownership i would later
but right now i think you're being very
wise to listen here's the thing
i owning a home
uh crap breaks
whether you're there or not
and it's just it adds you have a very
simple very clean very efficient life
and i would let someone else manage the
domicile
rather than you having a
let's say you had a roommate that
decided they want to sell all your
furniture on ebay while you were gone
that could happen
it's happened before
um
and so you get back the roommate's going
all your stuff's gone and you follow the
police report but
yeah i mean i've got a relatively new
house and i just got a report last week
i got to replace an air conditioner the
whole unit the whole thing yeah i don't
know why you want to do all that right
now i i think there's plenty of time as
young as you are to own a piece of real
estate i would wait at least 12 months
maybe 24 months and if you're home four
days
a month
rent the ritz
yeah i didn't think about that go to the
nicest hotel in atlanta it's just like
the ritz buckhead it's a nice property
i've stayed there
and just just for four nights
your life will be so much better people
will like bring food to your door and
stuff and they'll even come in your room
and set it up and you don't have to go
buy food you'll wash your towels it's
called room service and you don't have
to change the beds i mean it's an ama
that's what i would do and just have a
really nice efficient life and let my
energy be spent my spiritual emotional
physical energy be spent on something
other than home ownership for four days
a month
okay that makes a lot of sense
but i'm okay now long term i do want you
to buy so let's let's set a goal 25
years old you buy
because i think your life will change i
don't think you want to do this
indefinitely
this gypsy thing yes that makes sense
yeah it's going to be i mean that like
this is not conducive to family life
right no definitely not it's very much
you're living like a nomadic life yeah
yeah and it's kind of cool you're
getting to see a lot of stuff you're a
young guy it's kind of a you know little
uh uh yeah like you said nomadic that's
all cool all that's kind of fun i would
do it definitely do it if i was your
agent single i think it's kind of all
day long you get to see a lot of cities
and america's got some wonderful cities
you get to see some
cities that aren't wonderful that are
out there too if you do this for two
years you're going to blink
you could have 250 000 in cash yeah just
sitting there just keep piling up some
money and then just go buy you a house
but
not for four days a month no i wouldn't
i like real estate but it is not it is
the un the thing that nobody talks about
with rental real estate or personal
residences either one is they break yeah
and you have to have people come over
and fix crap you know and or fix it
yourself with your little youtube video
or whatever it is you're doing but oh my
gosh and on
and and there's
entire portions of my life have been
used up on broken stuff
around real estate you know that you
don't have to have if
on the short term if you're in his
situation so i i like to have in my all
my life back my bandwidth back to do
like fun stuff
or whatever or the four days you're home
just relax yeah and just have no house
have some peace no hassle no hassle no
house or no house yeah that's fun that's
fun it's fun to have no house